hey guys hope you're well i am done with
being at home i mean
literally for the last year i've been at
home in lockdown you've been at home in
lockdown
been leaving the house very limited and
i'm tired of it
so i have put together a property
investors training program
which i'm gonna be running next month
and guess what you
are invited so what's gonna happen is
it's gonna be a full day an intensive
day
and i'm gonna be teaching everything i
know about property and i'm gonna
condense it into a day
and the tickets are now available on the
website
and guess what because i'm so tired of
being a house because i'm so desperate
to see you there and i'm so excited
about seeing you win
the tickets
free okay which is just crazy
absolutely crazy listen i started in
property when i was
17 years old i bought my first house
aged 17
with no money i'm going to be showing
exactly how i did that and how you can
do the same thing too
i then built up a large portfolio
multi-million pound property portfolio
i'm gonna be showing you exactly how you
can do that too and then
i started doing crazy financial freedom
challenges you know literally all over
the different parts of the country
people say you know samuel could you
become financially free in manchester
could you do it in leeds
could you do it in swindon portsmouth
could you do it in birmingham warsaw
london watford guess what all the places
i just named
next month i'm going to be visiting i'm
not going to be coming financially free
i'm not going to be doing a free a
financial freedom challenge in those
cities
i'm going to be running a one day
advanced training program
for you to come and attend so that you
can do it in those cities
so if you're based um well wherever
you're based
come on down come on down spend a full
day with me it's amazing what happens
it's not been in the house so much man
and and all the people every single week
that have been coming on winners on a
wednesday are the people that have
actually
met me in person because when you meet
me in person
and we can actually start training and
you can see me doing live deals
which i'll be doing i'm gonna be doing
live
property deals condensing down
breaking everything down step by step
how to become financially free
when you're in that environment and you
see me do it
you're gonna start doing it so um
i could say i'm gonna do a big massive
event in london
but i'm not i'm gonna be touring and
traveling up and down the country
i'm gonna start in swindon portsmouth on
the 21st of june
then go down to birmingham uh watford
just outside london
and then i'm gonna be ending up north in
manchester and then ending in leeds so
from the 21st
right up until about i think the 29th
i'm gonna be touring
running my training the advanced
super training and uh and it's on the
house you can come for free
because i'm really done i'm just so sick
and tired
of not being able to be around people
and see lots of people where have high
energy
and i just love that i love training
people you know
ask me why do i train and it's because i
love
absolutely love seeing people succeed
but also i love the atmosphere
i love the energy i love the environment
so
not only that but also have these
training programs which are free
it's a really great chance to network as
well so maybe you're thinking
i don't want to go on a training course
i don't like training courses or
whatever all right fine
but come down just to network you know
we're probably going to have i don't
know maybe 200 people
at each each um location
and you're going to be able to network
with hundreds of other investors
hundreds of other people in property you
know i'm gonna be teaching you how to
package and sell deals maybe you'll meet
other investors at the training program
who've got money
and you can come down learn how to
package and sell deals and then
boom or maybe you can strike a joint
venture partnership
you know if you're too young if you're
too young to buy a property you can't
get a mortgage or you have not got good
credit
and you can't um get a buy to let
mortgage you know don't take yourself
out the game
because what i'm gonna be showing you
i'm gonna be teaching you how you can
joint venture with somebody
you find the deal but joint venture with
somebody where are you going to find the
joint venture partner
at the training next month everything's
the magic is going to happen next month
the magic is going to happen next month
june 21st
i'm so excited i'm done with
lockdown and i'm ready to meet you in
person so
the tickets are free they are limited so
you know what get your place registered
and do it right now
don't wait don't delay i'll leave a link
in the description property hyphen
invest uh property hyphen investors at
credit uk
forward slash crash course and
i'm so so excited um
and and also as well do a best case
worst case may be thinking can i be
bothered
um or can i be able to travel you know
sometimes people are saying samuel i'm
located
in belfast can you come to belfast i
can't come everywhere
i'm doing a tour all across england but
you know you're going to have to make a
move but when you make one move
i'll make 10. you know i'll make 10. but
best case worst case
what's the what's the worst case well
it's a free training program
worst case is you're going to come down
and you're going to be like that was
rubbish you're going to have wasted a
day
best case because you're going to come
down you're going to find a property
deal on the day
you'll sell it on the day who knows
final jiggy joint venture partner and
it's like is that realistic
well look how many thousands of people
have succeeded after coming to my
training programs on winners on a
wednesday every week
what they all got in common the thing
they've all got in common is that they
all came to the train they showed up
so i hope to see you i hope you show up
i'm not going to be disappointing
i'll be there personally myself and i'm
going to be delivering
training and i'm not going to hold back
so get yourself booked on i'll see you
next month
and if like me if you're done with just
being at home in lockdown and you're
ready to network you're ready to be
inspired
you're ready to make some money you're
ready to do some deals then uh get
registered but don't die don't
procrastinate because tickets are gonna
sell
they're going to sell out real fast i
just made it live i've not even really
promoted yet
and london is is the one in watford is
almost sold out
so get registered quickly i might even
be bringing my wifey
amanda are you going to come to the
crash courses yes
oh amazing see double whammy so if
you're not coming for me
if you don't care about me you're coming
for amanda look she's trying to run away
now
i'll be there she'll be there all right
so amanda's gonna be there i'm gonna be
there
you're gonna meet so many good people so
be there
and get booked now i'll leave the link
in the description god bless